tonight i'm going to ask questions and
demand answers that's what prosecutors
do
we don't know what motivated daryl
brooks brooks the assassin who tore
through the lives of multiple families
killing six and injuring 60 more
nor do i care to know his motive what i
care about is that thanksgiving didn't
happen for these families nor the
christmas holiday these folks began to
celebrate on that day
an innocent parade violently interrupted
by an evil force unleashed on the
streets of waukesha wisconsin it didn't
need to happen
tonight i ask why
not just as a prosecutor but as a mom
because americans deserve to be able to
go to parades and tree lightings and
malls without the threat of a career
criminal killing them
why
why are people like daryl brooks a
lifelong felon a career criminal a
convicted sex offender with multiple
felonies multiple firearm and assault
convictions a serial domestic violence
abuser who had an active warrant for
bail jumping who then ran over his
girlfriend with his car and is granted a
thousand dollars bail
why are these people allowed to continue
to act out their lives a violent crime
like brooks did last sunday why
how is it that eleven-year-old jessalyn
torres dancing in that christmas parade
lies unconscious today in a hospital
with a broken pelvis a broken femur a
fractured skull laceration to her lungs
and injury to her kidney
why did eight-year-old jackson sparks
parents have to bury him this holiday
season
why
why does this happen
i'll tell you why
because evil degenerates like brooks who
are a clear danger to the rest of us are
allowed to roam our streets because
democrat leftist legislators democrat
mayors progressive soros funded da's and
judges with their heads up in the clouds
and other places as well
allow them to they want them out they
don't care about you or any other victim
so when you go to the polls in november
of course the presidency congressional
representative senators incredibly
important positions but if you want
america to continue to exist every
township borough state house state
senate judicial race d.a race sheriff
phrase school board race is what you
need to focus on and focus fast
because these democrat da's legislators
and judges will continue their march to
keep criminals out of jail take a listen
to this one
breathe act proposes emptying federal
detention facilities within 10 years
to what extent have you wrestled with
any potential downsides of releasing
into society every single person who's
currently in a federal prison yeah
again i think that everyone's like oh my
god we're going to just release
everybody that's not what i'm saying
yeah but did you see how many people are
mentally ill that are in prison right
now no i know but the act that you so
actually says release everyone but in 10
years but think about it who will
release it if there are like human
traffickers oh i know
rashida talib
these people want to empty prisons of
those already convicted and literally
end law and order if we don't stop them
if we don't get them out of office they
are destroying america and the criminal
justice system they are a danger to you
your family your home and your business
the truth is that i have faith in the
criminal justice system i don't have
faith in many of the players who make
decisions before cases get to a jury and
neither should you
but when cases finally make it to a jury
we the people do the right thing
evidence
kyle rittenhouse was acquitted of
shooting three men
his case a textbook example of the legal
use of self-defense no matter how hard
the president the mainstream media and
race-baiters tried to make this about
white supremacy and domestic terrorism
and blm the jury saw the facts and
rendered a just verdict
evidence the three defendants charged
with the intentional murder of ahmad
aubry in georgia were all found guilty
that was a textbook example of racism
and hatred in action and but for one
juror all the jurors were white and they
convicted three white men of killing a
black man
no racism there
evidence george ford's george florence
murderer was a white cop derek chauvin a
jury convicted him of murder a white cop
convicted of killing a black man again
the proper verdict no racism there they
didn't need to burn down the streets and
businesses and cities and burn down
livelihoods
you see because americans are fair
americans get along we do it every day
in every part of this country and this
claim of racism comes from the
race-baiters and those who seek to
divide us for their own gain they want
to destroy america they want to teach
our children to hate us because we're
racist
the d.a in the daryl brooks christmas
parade case tried to blame the thousand
dollar bail on some low-level assistant
d.a who does this guy think he's kidding
d.a chisholm is a progressive who for
years let daryl brooks get away with all
kinds of crimes and did nothing not
ready for trial why because his office's
stated policy goes like this
quote we are focused on reducing the use
of incarceration in nearly all cases
overall
prosecutors prioritize addressing the
root causes of criminal behavior quote
trying to find ways to avoid prosecution
in more cases and to see what can be
done in terms of alternatives to
prosecution close quote
for one
i don't give a damn what the root causes
of criminal behavior are and neither
should you i only care about the victims
who never chose to be a part of the
system in the first place and a primer
bail is constitutional it's meant to
ensure the defendants return to court
and to consider how much of a danger the
individual is if not remanded
now this dirt bag was unleashed on the
streets by a d.a whose office is loaded
with progressive anti-victim programs
and it was chastised by a federal court
for a political investigation against
then governor walker he was more of a
political operative and a social justice
engineer than a real prosecutor
and ironically chisholm once admitted
that his progressive reforms would quote
get people killed quote you bet
guaranteed
but that didn't invalidate his urge to
let criminals run free
but with this leftist d.a was a judge
who was similarly incompetent this judge
was so inept so clueless or just woke or
just didn't give a damn but he allowed
someone already charged with the crime
of bail jumping to be bailed yet again
on a thousand dollars even when that
judge knew of the life of crime that
daryl brooks led for 22 years
victimizing others while he was allowed
to go free and live his best life
this can no longer be tolerated i don't
give a damn about the criminal or why he
or she does what they do i only care
about the victim and you better start
caring too because sooner or later
either you a member of your family
someone you care about someone you know
will have their lives disrupted torn
apart or destroyed by a dirt bag we knew
was a danger but that the leftists
didn't want to prosecute
do you have the will and the courage to
pursue justice on behalf of crime
victims in america because every time a
victim is ignored or a crime goes
unpunished or violence is excused under
these progressive leftist hateful
anti-american
mayors democrats our society erodes
further becomes harder meaner and more
violent
and no one wants to believe that
predators and murderers roam freely in
our midst or the brutal acts are
committed all the time by people who
should be in jail
but make no mistake the path we are on
right now unless we stop it will lead to
the destruction not only of the criminal
justice system but america as the land
of the free and the land of justice
and that's my open
let me know what you think on my
facebook and twitter
judge jeanine hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else